hey it's me Tommy B and I want to talk
about the bad batch and maybe the
baddest of the bad batch your favorite
my favorite
Omega now we all know everybody in the
bad batch has their own specific ability
or skill Tech master of gadgets
calculations record superhuman strength
Hunter can hear his senses are Amplified
but I want to talk about Omega perhaps
being something more perhaps being Force
sensitive and I thought episode 6 of
season 2 tribe really showcased that
because she somehow sensed gunji was
being held captive by those droids in
that Droid Mafia and she knew and it's
been hinted before in the series her
having bad feelings or bad senses about
things is she Force sensitive did gunji
somehow call out to her and convince her
that he needed to be saved and did she
sense that she's now meditating a lot
are we about to see a clone Jedi that's
what I'm asking I think we might be hell
yeah